a friend of mine told me that just years
ago that when he meets new people or
makes new friends that he always hopes
that he leaves that person but just a
little bit better off than than before
they met and I also kind of have that
mentality now with with the businesses
and the things that I do is that just
want to yeah
leave it better than we found it and so
I think that really that really drives
me and I'm very passionate about uh yeah
and just making people's lives a little
bit better
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today we are with Joe Natoli who has
many titles throughout his career actor
game designer educator full stack
developer and entrepreneur his passion
for delighting people through technology
has led him to found it Luft the world's
first cooling and heating Comfort
Service Company while working at
Adventure builder in Leipzig Germany he
brings knowledge of international
startups Silicon Valley and more having
worked with billionaire investor Tim
Draper from Draper University teaching
entrepreneurship around the world from
Africa to Asia afterwards he settled in
Europe to put his knowledge to work by
forming ventures in the underserved
Market of Eastern Germany Joe could be
considered the ultimate startup Guy
having built founded or failed over a
dozen startup businesses
your journey is so interesting and so I
am so curious to hear about the
different things that you've done from
entrepreneurial to educational to invest
investment to consumer appliances and
where you're today you're building them
to leave you feeling magical I just love
that statement how tell me a little bit
about you know connect the dots for me
about your journey because you've done
so many awesome things what's been sort
of this Common Thread throughout your
your path and and it feels like this
idea of feeling magical is uh it's a
probably an a a recurring event
throughout these different experiences
no you're actually not wrong at all on
on that that threat I think that's a
really key thread and actually I think
that first magical kind of um uh
motivation came from back when I was in
in my college studies University I was
actually studying game design and
development
um which is totally different than than
where I ended up
um but back then I was doing a lot of
like 3D animation and teaching myself
around I mean it's a lot of design game
design involves everything from the 3D
stuff to like player system and all this
this stuff but
um in animation specifically we've got a
big thick book around Disney Animation
it's actually very famous in the
animation community and uh and as with
everything in Disney it was all about
like making things kind of like extra uh
magical and extra extra fun and
interesting for people like adding the
little bounces or the little like
special just animations that that Disney
used to put in their old hand-drawn
stuff and then I think I just carried
that with me through through into
entrepreneurship once I transitioned
into uh into entrepreneurship
um uh jumping forward when I was uh
working with this guy over in Silicon
Valley Tim Draper at his hero University
they have this uh this uh hero pledge
and and just part of the the ethos there
also is delighting your customer and
making it magical for them uh as uh one
of his Investments way back in the day
said that they wanted to do that and it
kind of stuck with him and then he
passed it on to us well while we were
working with them so that actually kind
of has been a threat and that I just
want to want to surprise and Delight
people maybe if it's through a game or
in the user inter experience or a piece
of Hardware like that that magic I think
is super special and Me Remember
products that make us feel feel good and
and the widest in some way
where where did you discover that this
was a core passion of yours to create
these magical experiences what you know
from an entrepreneur's perspective was
there some trigger for you that said
okay this is what I'm this is what I'm
into this is what entrepreneurship is
for me was it working with Tim Draper
Disney animations what was it for you
yeah I mean that that still probably
just goes back to when I was a kid and
been playing a lot of yeah honestly
playing games like that's what I I
wanted to uh I bumped playing games and
then also acting that was the other
thing and I think acting as well there's
an element of like delight and
surprising the the audience and I think
that that's where that came from and
with entrepreneurship you're when you're
selling something to somebody you have
to convince them that it's going to
benefit their life in some way right and
one ways that we benefit is When Things
become easier or magical uh that that's
part of the uh the Delight in in
everyday objects that we we tend to love
uh when we look at our phone we don't
really know how it works but it it
surprises the hell out of us and
delights the hell out of us when we can
go on whatever the Instagram the tick
tocks right um and so that that uh that
threat was just I feel like it's really
important to bring to entrepreneurship
in general where a lot of stuff can seem
overly salesy or overly produced or or
whatever it is or inauthentic a lot of
times and so I wanted to bring all right
yeah I believe in authenticity and uh
and that's where that kind of came from
did that answer your question yeah no no
for sure and as you're as you go around
because obviously and you look at the
different organizations that you've
found that are co-founded I mean they're
very different right I mean perhaps they
have this connected this connection
around building these great products but
but they are different what is the
process that you go through to determine
where you're going to be devoting most
of your time and energy into an
entrepreneurial Journey how do you even
go through that process whether it be
basic loofed Etc
sure sure so just uh to lay the the
groundwork as you kind of mentioned
because obviously people aren't going to
have my bio so I'll go over to some of
the projects to to show how wide of a
range you're actually discussing here
yeah yeah basic t-shirts uh was a
project that I I did uh quite a long
time ago and it was a lot of people
start with t-shirts as like or clothes
as they're one of their first
entrepreneurial Avengers it's very low
low barrier of Entry to get into and so
we meet a friend of mine wanted to to
start this t-shirt company but I was
also into technology and like adding
that value ad on top of something and so
basic was a one-for-one t-shirt company
where if you bought something we would
help somebody with a basic need food
water or shelter and on the Garment we
had a QR code and I developed the
encoded the system where you could scan
the QR code and then choose if you
wanted to help somebody with food water
or shelter and then we would help uh
based on what you chose and if you got
the Garment second hand then you could
also scan the code and see like how we
helped who would help and kind of the
story behind that shirt which was which
was pretty cool uh well from there uh
some of the other Ventures I founded
were recently is um we had a something
here in Germany called DaVinci kitchen
which is a food robot uh that uses a
robotic arm to make make pasta uh within
three minutes like fresh cooked super
cool pasta that you can just it's open
uh 24 7 just in a quarter there's this
box that you can go to put in an order
and it makes you a fresh pasta and then
uh from there we also have uh like a
contract changing app to keep um your
your uh your contracts or
um at one point I was also doing like uh
Tim like this one I don't know why but
uh this is what I pitched when I was
there which was like a uh you could
locate a bathroom like uber for
bathrooms almost where you could find
like a really really high-end bathroom
if you're out in public and just needed
to go wanted the Privacy have nice feet
have nice amenities you know the really
high quality toilet paper the whatever
just to take a break if you really
wanted to find it
um sponsored bathroom thing and he he
always joked about the bathroom idea he
loved it for some reason I don't know
why
um so yeah I've had this wide variety of
of uh companies that I've kind of gone
through from kind of basic e-commerce
Drop Shipping type businesses with the
T-shirt thing all the way into high tech
um as well and when I try to think about
businesses
um it really comes down to I'm into like
pattern matching and Trend uh watching
so I would consume a lot of business
related content whether it's podcasts or
articles or YouTube and then I stay on
top to stay on top of the latest trends
uh as well I'm in the tech and then I
tried to find
um kind of connection points between the
different uh businesses so if you're
talking about food and food production
we were working with a client who
happened to be like an international
catering company we saw the rise of
Robotics and around on-demand stuff and
so we kind of come in my mind I combined
the things and tried to make it fit
together to form a business I uh
so it's a little bit of opportunity like
searching for opportunities being on top
of technology and then just looking for
patterns like oh this is a really
interesting business model how can I
take it over here to make this thing
even cooler or more interesting
um it's not just um
it's not just a decision to to work on
these different projects but you know
that are interesting for you it's also a
decision to go on these entrepreneurial
Journeys where you literally have to
build a foundation not to to even see
some products come to life so you know
what what part of you makes it be that
you that you are sort of an a Visionary
behind them and then the entrepreneurial
figure Behind These businesses because
it's not just saying okay now I'm going
to work and I'm going to now I'm going
to work on all these different areas but
you're actually actively saying I'm
actually going to be a Visionary within
these areas where I'm going to attempt
to be a leading figure thought wise on
how these industries need to advance
where is that coming from
that's a that's a great question and it
almost sounds like a uh a question one
of my parents would ask me anyway which
is which is interesting like where do
you come up with this stuff why well how
do you how do you even think about this
and yeah uh I I I don't think that I
have like a good good answer for that
because for me it's almost
it like an innate thing where I'm just
kind of doing it all the time it's my
brain is just if I'm walking around I'm
thinking about stuff
um even if I'm listening to podcasts and
doing stuff it's just kind of like
running in in my background or I'll just
all of a sudden have this spark thought
because I heard one thing maybe that's
what it is is that I'm just consuming so
much content and then I'm thinking on my
content on how to connect the dots and
then from there I take the the vision
and say hey I think the world really
needs this thing and this would be very
cool uh and then I've I'm lucky to have
connected myself to resources to then
push these ideas forward
um Into The Ether in some way whether
it's with the partners that I used to
work at with the Venture Builder or in
Silicon Valley with all the people that
I was teaching maybe I kind of just
spread around the ideas there and
influence people that way
um but then it it's just yeah maybe it's
thick the that I've surrounded myself
with a network or connections to
actually push the Visions out into the
world
well fantastic so Luft take me on the
Journey of Luft first of all awesome
great name thank you I'm actually glad
you said that Luft comes from the the
German word uh for air uh Luft it's
spelled a-u-f-t
um yeah air air yeah I I for some reason
have a thing for double letters I heard
one time this is just a bit of
information that double letter sticking
her head more often like for Brands and
stuff like the Google Yahoo Apple
Facebook Apple yeah for some reason
double letters are like uh good and so I
I don't have a double letter in my name
I need to I need to work on that yeah no
no I'm changing my name this is it
um then Michael with two K's or is it or
uh yeah there's two C's where's it well
Mike I don't need people to remember
Michael but my startup Clarity is just
and there's no repeating letter so I'm
gonna I'm calling my co-founder right
after this and and you're responsible
for that conversation it's a repeating
letter
um yeah I'm gonna start calling myself
Joe with two o's so people really
remember it
um but no so we just changed the loop to
the looped with the the double O and the
journey of lift is actually pretty
interesting because it started as a B2B
business as I mentioned I was working at
a venture Builder uh here in Germany
it's what brought me away from Silicon
Valley I wanted to come over to Germany
to to see what I could do to apply my
skills and start some businesses here
had I had more information around
Germany in general and Eastern Germany
where I ended up maybe I would have had
a different decision because it's uh
East versus West Germany there's a whole
history here that I just was ignorantly
uh and uh anyways so we were doing a B2B
business with uh one of our our partners
what we did is we partnered with
corporates and then we helped them
um do Innovation by providing startups
that they can invest in uh we we thought
of the startups we ideate with them to
see what problems they're seeing in the
industry and then try to solve those
problems and so we knew that in the US
market there was like a lot of
um one air conditioning and two
um like inefficient uh units especially
with window air conditioners or through
the wall units which are very common in
like hotels motels and then uh in the
the the lower southern hemisphere uh or
hemisphere the southern part of the
United States and then over in New York
uh these kind of places and people have
these really outdated machines and so
what we wanted to do was provide cooling
as a service to businesses uh where you
buy a big enterprise system for a
building and then you install it for
them so the construction cost goes down
it's a somebody else purchases the HVAC
system and then they pay you a monthly
fee for you to then run the system
optimize it and and make sure that their
air in their big building is is good
it's called cooling as a service it's
kind of growing in popularity in in um
in uh like developing nations uh
especially where the costs are are more
of a concern and so we wanted to take
this methodology of cooling into a
service and and bring it to more of a
consumer thing and so originally we
wanted to just uh buy a bunch of
machines like new high-end air
conditioners give them to hotels and
then operate them for them and Link them
all together and kind of uh make it more
efficient like to reduce power
um and then we were finding Founders for
it we had find Founders that weren't me
uh we had an idea we had everything
lined up and then covet hit and it's
probably a story you're hearing over and
over and over again covet hit and then
the world stopped everyone's like we
don't know what we're gonna do and then
it just kind of paused we lost the
founders the the idea kind of went away
and priorities shifted and then as
covert was kind of coming out of it a
year and a half later we looked we
looked at the project and uh we realized
that because I was a U.S citizen and
this was kind of targeted towards the US
that maybe I should take over it and so
I did but I I'm not a I don't know I
wasn't feeling the whole hotel motel
angle I'm as you have kind of found out
more into like magical consumer
experiences and so
um I had been delighted by another
another company
um called whoop where I kind of learned
about this business model that roof now
has double O applied yeah I have also
the double O and then I applied their
business model to what we were doing
with cooling as a service and we came up
with Luft which is a what we call the
world's first Comfort Service
um it's a model where you pay for like a
12-month contract with us for uh the
service and the service includes
analytics you get to learn about your
comfort you get to learn about your
environment and then we also include a
device with the the membership that is
pretty much the the same as buying any
other air conditioner so your total cost
is exactly the same but we have all this
value on top of it so we send you the
air conditioner you link it up and then
our sensor is taking information from
the inside of the room outside the room
uh local weather apis all of the units
together on the network and then it
optimizes itself based on how you use it
so it learns about your usage patterns
preferences and habits and then
hopefully our algorithm which we've been
testing works as good as we want we can
reduce your costs by just our technology
because it's so new up to 40 and then
with our algorithm on top of it an
additional 10 to 15 percent and the
reason we wanted to do that is because
we were reading some articles that said
hey if we can increase the efficiency by
just eight percent of these types of
units that we can possibly prevent
rolling blackouts or in cities as the
world gets warmer and warmer and so our
goal is just to reduce blackouts but
really uh the overall goal is to help
people learn more about themselves their
comfort their environment and then
reduce their their electrical costs
while also saving the environment
because if we can reduce costs and
increase electricity reduce the
greenhouse gas emissions the carbon
emissions the waste then hopefully we
can you know make the world a better
place uh leave it more than how we found
it you know
that's really cool so you're directed
competing with incumbents that have been
selling air conditioners you know these
big brands for free for decades right I
mean this is at least I know from the
areas that I'm in I mean there's only so
many few companies that would provide
these services
how do you how are you experiencing the
market reaction to coming in to such
sort of like an old uh brand heavy
market and you're all of a sudden coming
and disrupting it as a startup
uh what kind of what I can tell you it's
very challenging that's that's the
easiest way that I can break it down
it's extremely extremely challenging
um we are very much underdogs in several
senses of the word both like uh with
production and with the uh money with
everything
um and the reactions honestly if I'm
Gonna Be Be candid is that we have heard
the same sorts of um of concerns and uh
frightened ideology from like other
investors that we've approached to to
help grow our company uh how are you
going to possibly compete against the
big guys uh and I mean it's pretty much
the same way that anyone competes with
with people offer a better service offer
a better product have a better brand uh
and so that's kind of what we're
building up to it's something that's
going to going to disrupt the incumbents
because we're changing the business
model we're shaking up on its head
um and they're not going to know how to
compete with it or in the long run it
does really well and then they we get
eaten up on them I mean this is also a
business right this this type of stuff
eventually happens
um or it can potentially happen but it's
just a matter of offering something
better at a more affordable price that's
more interesting to Consumers which we
think we've uh We've we've nailed
what I enjoy most about this journey not
just this journey you know I'm looking
now
generalizing over the different
entrepreneurial Journeys you've had what
what do you really enjoy most out of
them so you really had to distill it to
just a couple of really key elements
that really do it for you
the really the thing that I enjoy the
most uh is the fact that uh as I just
kind of alluded to it and mentioned that
I can leave the world uh better than how
I found it I think a friend of mine told
me that just years ago that when he
meets new people or makes new friends
that he always hopes that he leaves that
person
um but just a little bit better off than
than before they met and I also kind of
have that mentality now with with the
businesses and the things that I do is
that just want to yeah
leave it better than we found it and so
I think that really that really drives
me and I'm very passionate about uh yeah
and just making people's lives a little
bit better
I love it I love it Joe thank you so
much for coming here and for sharing
with me this time and your energy and I
can't wait to follow Luther and all the
other different uh experiences that
you're going to be building for the
world it sounds like you have such a
clear conviction on the type of
entrepreneur that you are and the type
of things that excite you and motivate
you and so I mean I'm looking forward to
cheering from the side and in the
meantime thank you for coming here and
giving me a glimpse into your journey
with a lot of curiosity and inspiration
thank you
no thank you for having me and I hope
your audience enjoyed the conversation
and uh and uh good luck on Switching the
name to it just end up adding those
double letters in
I appreciate it thank you
[Music]